one of the requests I get more often
than any others in the comments section
of YouTube is to share some of my
favorite books some of the books I found
the most helpful in business in fitness
and working out in self-development
psychology and so that's what I'm gonna
do now for now I just want to share some
of my favorite business and productivity
that have helped me with my online
endeavors deep work by Cal Newport as
someone who regularly writes 15,000
words or more a day this book really
speaks to me it discusses the importance
of working for intense undisturbed
periods now to get the most from those
stints turns out you can get a heck of a
lot done when you aren't answering
emails all day or doing admin or dealing
with other communication overhead I wish
more businesses would read this book
because managers can learn a lot from it
by just letting their staff actually get
to work instead of pestering them all
the time probably my favorite concept in
here is the idea of productive
meditation this is meditation where the
objective isn't to completely empty your
mind but rather to dedicate some set
time to solving a problem or creative
challenge the personal MBA by Josh
Kaufman this book promises to be an MBA
in book form like the 4-hour workweek
that promises of course a little
hyperbolic what it is though is a
particularly comprehensive guide to
business that more than anything teaches
you to adopt the right mindset and to
see the bigger picture in business I
think the most important tip is to
understand your value proposition as per
the old saying you don't sell hats you
sell warm heads keys to understand the
emotional drive that your product or
service has how can you make your
customers lives better
how will they feel understanding this
will lead to far better branding and
marketing then there's the idea of
counterfactual simulation which is where
you run through possible futures in your
head and wonder whether or not you're
prepared for them in the book Josh
Callen talks about how this can help
with your business's resilience but I
also like to use this in my personal
life for instance if I'm going somewhere
and I'm not sure if I've remembered
everything I need to bring with me then
I simulate what's gonna happen in my
head and at each step ask if I've got
the thing that I need at that point in
the simulation thriving in the gig
economy freelancing online for tech
professionals and entrepreneurs by
adamson its key biased me surely not
this is of course my book and it's one
that unsurprisingly
I
also recommend it's a guide to working
online as a freelancer which is one of
the decisions that I made that
ultimately contributed most greatly to
my happiness
productivity health and lifestyle I
design this book to provide everything
you might need to know when starting out
your own business online one point I'm
particularly proud of though is the
description of the transhuman business
model a concept that I managed to sneak
into a technical book somehow the
general idea here is that you can scale
a one-man business by increasing your
own efficiency to superhuman degrees in
other words you don't have to increase
the rate you charge if you can increase
your output and being self-employed
means that the only limit on this is
your own capabilities new thinking by
dagoba I'll trade you can tell that I
like this book because my testimonial is
on the front cover I've worked with the
go-go aka cold fusion so I know
firsthand that he's a stand-up guy as
well as extremely interesting and
talented that's the side though this
book is a fascinating look at the impact
of various technologies throughout
history and as someone who loves the
impact that an individual mind or a
single idea can make on the future it's
just a great tour highlights include
quantum computing and the opening look
at Nikola Tesla the 4-hour workweek by
Tim Ferriss this is the book on
lifestyle design and in some ways the
one that started it all lifestyle design
is essentially the goal of creating a
business model primarily designed to
work within the lifestyle you want
rather than the other way around
there are plenty of productivity tips in
here as well as practical strategies for
earning passive income I was already
working online and making money from an
app when I read this so I knew a lot of
that what was more profound to me was
the invitation to question what I was
actually trying to achieve with all that
hard work this brought me to the
realization that I work so that I can
spend more time with the people I love
and doing the things I love progressing
further and further in an organization
or even with your own business taking on
more and more responsibility aiming to
earn megabucks
in general won't lead you to that point
you can actually normally do this
without even working a normal 9 to 5 and
Tim is generally a legend
so thanks ton for watching guys hit
fence video useful interesting if you
did them please leave a like and share
it around that helps me out immensely
and let me know down below what some of
your favorite books are thanks a ton for
watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now
you